Hi everyone,
You are on English Online,
the Business English series.
Today we are following on with our second tip for
building resilience, so let’s jump straight in.
Tip number two is about using different writing
techniques to gain a more objective perspective.
This might sound like a
strange one, but bear with me.
I was never someone who was into keeping diaries
or writing journals or anything like that, but
even I have clearly seen some benefits of applying
writing techniques into my day-to-day life.
As humans, we tend to have this ability
to over-exaggerate everything, and make
everything seem way worse than it actually is.
This is true for both positive
and negative situations.
When encountering a negative situation, by taking
a couple of minutes to write down what happened,
and I mean what actually happened, some facts and
some bullet points, it allows us to remove our
emotions that may have clouded our judgement and
it allows us to gain a more objective perspective.
This morning’s meeting was an
absolute mess. We were late
starting. The presentation really didn’t
go down well. Felt like an absolute idiot,
how embarrassing. I think that we need to make
lots of improvements. He seemed super unimpressed.
That meeting did not go well, okay,
so. Meeting was at 10am. We were
meeting to discuss the contract. Negative
aspects, negative aspects and positives,
well, I felt like I didn’t speak very well.
Taking a minute to jot down ten bullet points
will take less than 10 minutes, so next time
you encounter a difficult situation, try this:
Write down four facts and
figures from the situation,
three positives and three negative outcomes
and make sure that you are objective.
We can also look at our reaction and
if there’s anything that we would’ve
changed or done differently. This helps
us to be more prepared for the next time
that we encounter a similar situation and
teaches us to take things less personally.
Alternatively, you may be somebody who
writes down or jots down any of the little
things that is annoying them, frustrating
them or getting them down. By doing this,
you can also practise the art of letting go by
burning the sheet of paper with all of these
annoyances or ripping it up, blowing it away and
letting go of all of your stress and worries.
If you can think of any other writing techniques
that you have benefitted from to help build
resilience and lower your stress level then
please share them in the comments below.
If you’ve liked our video today guys, please stay
tuned. You can subscribe to the channel below
and keep up to date with the rest of our content.
Our third and final tip for building
resilience is coming soon. You can also
take a look by clicking on the link here to
view the other videos on things like conflict
management. Thanks for watching
guys, I’ll see you again next time.